today on living by faith we have six
seven eight ten disease you see depicted
like this yes early
my mother had Parkinson cancer diabetes
authorizer this hydro-pressure and these
are all nutritional deficiency diseases
it comes down to two things the
nutrients that are required to prevent
and cure these diseases are no longer
see half the supplements to get rid of
[Music]
well welcome to another broadcast of
living by faith and I gotta tell you
this is probably one of the most
important broadcast that you would ever
want to pay attention to because if you
don't begin to pay attention to this
particular subject of this broadcast you
may not be around very long to see a lot
of other broadcasts because this is
about your health it's about your health
and if anyone knows the importance of a
healthy lifestyle and having healthy
practices is this guy here some of you
have already heard you've been aware of
the fact that I went through a very
tumultuous time health-wise about two
and a half years ago and thank God that
we have this healing plan in the
covenant that God has established with
us and then we have men of God who are
called to help us with healthy practices
so that we can have great lives you know
he was wounded for our transgressions
and bruised for our iniquities but
there's a role that we have in this
whole healing plan and I have one of the
body of Christ this right here in my
presence and I'm honored to introduce
dr. Joel Wallach he is one of the
leaders and the knowing the importance
of maintaining a healthy lifestyle let
me welcome him at this time dr. Wallach
my pleasure sir well thank you so much
pastor mica yeah pleasure and thank you
so much for the kind words yes sir quite
deserving I I want to firstly make sure
people are calling their friends and
their family members those who they are
concerned about having a healthy life to
our broadcast so get your friends and
family members and co-workers all the
people you want to see live a long time
that's the group you want to call now
now the Bible says if you have an aunt
again someone go to them and let them
know that you haven't ought the ought
that I have had against you you've taken
too long to be in this chair to talk to
me so I'm letting you know today that
I'm just thrilled to have you here and
it's taken a while but what we made it
well I appreciate your taking so much
time out of your busy schedule and you
think this happened I've watched you on
many different ministries Bennion creflo
dollar there's there's so many and I
said what won't this guy come and see me
but nevertheless you're here now let's
talk about the importance of a healthy
lifestyle just give me a little
background of yourself how did you get
started
when did the Lord called you to this
area of ministry okay um well actually
started when I was four years old Wow
Tru Calling really yes sir
and when I was four years old I began to
get symptoms of what today would be
called Tourette's syndrome as part of
the ATD ADHD hyperactivity autism
complex yes sir
but back then they were all kind of
lumped into one thing it was called
hyperactivity and everybody knew was
caused by red food dye in the food
mm-hmm and started getting facial cramps
and ticks and oinking like a pig and and
everybody in church I was possessed by
the devil right I'm only four years old
yeah yeah
and my mom and dad took me to 20
different doctors over a period of five
years come all the time I was nine I was
very disabled because I couldn't read
and that sort of thing so just barely
making it through school I think they
were just passing me so it wouldn't have
a big like an another class all the time
oh yes sir
and after the 20th doctor I'm saying to
myself well it doesn't look like any of
these people can help me so the next day
when everybody else in school went to
lunch I went to the library yes I went
the librarian said look I can't read
nine years old yes sir okay you're going
to I was being guided yeah absolutely
and so I went to the library I said look
I can't read but I need to have a book I
can look at pictures and simple words
and it needs to be a health book and the
librarian said well there's some nurses
hand books in the back there's a one
little paperback that was perfect and
the last doctor had said that my
eyelashes were too long they were
ticking tickling my eyeballs that was
causing all this mom only nine years old
and I knew that couldn't be right and so
you're nine years old and you're saying
but they said couldn't be right now do
you believe that was by the Spirit of
God or how does a nine year old that's I
see that all the time of my presentation
there's no way that a nine year old
figures of sobbing yes sir it had to be
driven driven and guided by the hand of
God only could do that mm-hmm I have no
qualms I have no questions I know that's
what happened and I started looking
under eyelids and eyelashes to see and I
couldn't find anything so I just started
going through the A's and the B's and
got to the season and said cramps oh
well maybe this is a cramp because
football players are always talking
about cramps went to the pages said to
go to and it says caused by calcium
deficiency
well that lit up a light at me because
before the bus would pick me up in the
morning to take me to school
I had farm chores to do him one of which
was to feed the calves out of this big
paper bag of alfalfa pellets with corn
and soybeans and vitamins and minerals
in it and I could read the analysis tag
instead I remember it had calcium in it
and so that day after school most let me
know if I just ran right to the barn
start eating handfuls of these little
come on yeah tastes like sawdust but I'm
saying yeah yeah yeah yes sir and I
filled my pockets with it the next day
for breakfast I threw the Cheerios out
into the front yard with the chickens
I'm filling my cereal bowl with these
alfalfa pillows for the calves
no wonder your parents saying at this
dances away from you that's animal food
you can't be
okay my dad took it away from hearses
look nothing else has worked for five
years let's let him try it
Wow so he gives it back to me the third
day pasture I was cured after five years
getting worse and worse worse being
totally disabled in three days I was
perfectly cured Tom all the story gets
better
talk to me after a couple of weeks in
church people are noticing that I'm not
only like a pig and having my facial
tics in ain't ya kind of thing and
flailing my arms around and disrupting
everything yeah what was life like that
well I was a kid everybody
yeah and teasing you and well then
wasn't when there was a group of them
they would teach me one of them by
themselves they wouldn't want to be
around because they knew I was possessed
by the devil
yeah so after a couple of weeks people
are whispering and pointing to me in the
church because they noticed that I've
changed yeah nobody said anything to
them but they're noticing after the
third week this lady and her 80s comes
to me and says I have diabetes can you
help me now that frightened me I'm a kid
and I'm a kid I don't know what to do I
don't know you're still not mm-hmm
there's only a couple of weeks later and
so I began to read up on diabetes and so
on and of course I wanted to know more
about all this healing I was reading
about and being taught in Sunday school
in the Bible and so when I went to
college
first thing I did was go to agricultural
school okay so one day I just want to be
a scientific farmer go back to you know
scientific farmer halfway through AG
school and I applied for veterinary
school got accepted so the last two
years of AG school I took the first two
years of venturi school finished AG
school and I had to do the ROTC because
of a Vietnam War was on numerous misery
so when I finished actual I also
graduated as an officer and gentleman in
the US Army how about that and then I
finish my very work but I also started
taking pathology courses looking at
disease because interested in diseases
and all of this you believe it's a part
of the leading of holy spirit that's
correct we got to stop right there we're
gonna come right back
and continue this this interesting and
fascinating testimony I want you to know
that this is an opportunity for you to
receive information that's going to
cause your life to be transformed
health-wise you get your soul right you
get your body right your spirit is
already in the place we're gonna be
right back to hear the rest of this
awesome testimony and then talk about
some of dr. Walker's products you can
actually avoid reverse prevent all
chronic degenerative diseases not
emergen etic and we've used this system
and animals we've been able to reverse
these diseased animals every disease you
can name we've been able to do it and
for 36 years I've been employing these
principles in my human patients it works
every time it'll work for you too my
wife had struggled for quite a few years
I had chronic fatigue
I had arthritis I had carpal tunnel I
could not go up and down stairs without
grabbing the rail and walking up each
foot on each step to get up we heard
about dr. Wallach we went to his first
meeting and it's been uphill ever since
I can run up and down the stairs now my
younger sister her help was worse than
mine her legs would go out on her she'd
just be down on the floor doctors had
told her it's hereditary there's nothing
we can do for you and eventually you
will be in a wheelchair
she had severe fibromyalgia ringing in
the ears and asthma and she would spend
most of her day sitting on the couch she
was wishing that she could die and
praying that she would and within a
month of having absolutely wonderful
results her legs have never gone out on
her once she has not had an asthma
attack the ringing in their ears is
almost gone not quite completely but she
does no longer has fibromyalgia and she
is energetic and going like I am we've
had the opportunity to introduce over
300 people and we've seen amazing
results from
different people with almost everything
you can imagine we have two people in
our group who completely got enough from
their diabetes medicine and having
better results than when they were on
the prescription drugs I'm a firm
believer in dr. Wallach I love what he's
done and is doing for people hi I'm dr.
Joel Wallach and I'm gonna give you the
truth about nutrition what I would like
you to do is give me 90 days to show
what the 90 essential nutrients can do
for your health how we're back and thank
you for watching let's let's go right
back into where you were sure sure
continue okay Pastor Mike I was
finishing up veterinary school when I
started taking pathology courses because
I kind of liked you could always find
the answer what killed people yeah and
what killed animals and so I was doing
that and I ran into the fast I ran into
the first mass die-off in America in
evolution and got it written up I'm only
21 years old I'm a graduate student got
written up published mm-hmm I gave
copies to important people in the
university and tomorrowland Perkins me
Old Mutual Mohawk Kingdom show mm-hmm
and when I graduated Perkins I had
worked for him as a kid little kid he
sent me to Africa to work on the white
rhino conservation project and an
African elephant conservation project
okay and then two years into that he
sends me a letter said look I just got
this big grant to study pollution as a
cause of death and people cuz it's back
in the mid-60s when everybody knew the
earth was going to end in two weeks from
pollution so I need to have you come
back and be the pathologist on this
project make a long story short it was a
12 year project like 25 million dollars
mm-hmm which is a lot of money for a 24
old kid oh absolutely
and to make a long story short 20,000
autopsies 17,000 some change of over 454
species of animals and then 3,000 humans
and looking for pollution as a cause of
death in these zoo animals and people
because the people were getting the same
food supply to the animals were from the
wholesalers grocery stores from the
wholesalers to the zoo's okay and again
to make a long story short what it found
was pollution had nothing to do with
causes of death and the zoo animals or
humans it was all nutritional deficient
all nutritional deficiencies cause heart
disease and diabetes and arthritis and
alzheimers disease and so on and I knew
how to prevent these and cure them and
the book that came out with 1200 pages
which was my thesis for my postdoc which
is my PhD essentially lissa it's in the
Smithsonian Institute as a national
treasure because I found out the cause
of all these diseases were not genetic
and we're not out of moon even sickle
cell anemia and that got Andy young and
there's a rights movement all excited
about it I can prevent I can prevent
sickle cell anemia even everybody the
whole family's got it the next babies
won't have it and I can actually deal
with it much more efficiently than with
drugs using nutrition I've been finding
type 2 diabetes in crocodiles now how
does a crocodile get a human genetic
disease so don't turns I was just all
simple nutritional mm-hmm
this began to be the basis of me
following what God started when I was 5
years old to treat people with his stuff
the food and the lifestyle yes sir
so that and the Bible always rails
against pharmakeia
right yeah mmm absolutely and so I began
to do this and I'm finding cures for
diseases or said to be genetic in kids
I'm finding cures for diseases or said
to be Jamaican the black community like
high blood pressure and the LEAs and the
obesity yes sir congestive heart failure
Al's hammer disease these are all simple
disease that you totally prevent in
Reverse just totally prevent and reverse
and reverse I can make your church
family disease free and six months or
less come all using his methods I love
it
now now when let me take it back yeah
right right it does and I'm sure all of
our viewers are watching and saying and
wondering how and where has this man
been well it comes down to again after
those 20,000 autopsies the bottom line
of what I learned was that every
vertebrae whether a crocodile or a
turtle or a fish or human being or a rat
or a flamingo or an elephant or draught
all vertebrates require the same basic
nutrients if you're missing any of them
you get diseases you know the same
deficiency in a crocodile will give you
the same deficiency in a human same
disease mm-hmm
nobody never seen it before because say
an expert in one particular disease it
might do an autopsy on 500 white rats
okay our fifty dogs mm-hmm nobody's ever
done four hundred and fifty four species
of animals in one project plus humans
and so I know that had to be a god thing
because no man could put that together
now now back up for a moment because
when you are four this happens yes okay
nine you begin to eat the animal food
the animal food all this is it's
connecting to your purpose and what God
had it's right he is training me
training you through this process that's
correct
and then you are given grant you're
given these opportunities to create all
of these studies yes sir
and and then you come to find out with
the relationship that you have with the
Lord and the relationship that you have
with plant-based eating food you you now
have discovered how to totally eradicate
in someone like me high blood pressure
diabetes but an african-american man
okay it's not uncommon for any human
being regardless of race to have six
seven eight ten disease you see it
people like this only
yes sir my mother had Parkinson's cancer
diabetes yes otherwise it's high blood
pressure and these are all nutritional
deficiency diseases and it comes down to
two things the nutrients that are
required to prevent and cure these
diseases that are no longer found in our
food so you have to supplement to get
rid of him
so what is all of this medication doing
that she was prescribed and taking with
the exception of antibiotics which can
cure syphilis and
disease and bacterial pneumonia okay
prescription drugs the only one that
cures anything as antibiotics all other
prescription drugs pastor are designed
to relieve symptoms and people are very
grateful oh I was in such pain for years
I take this new painkiller these opioids
and no more pain but the disease keeps
getting worse in five or ten years later
they die prescriptions are only treating
the symptoms not the disease absolutely
so the things that you have given me are
new and I can I can tell the significant
difference in my life
pressures good no diabetes none of the
above the same things that my mother and
father
well my father didn't have the Parkinson
but they were that when I went to the
doctor he was saying well if your mother
has this and your father has this I'm a
mother will get prepared you know this
is a false theory there's been thousands
of false theories every century going
back to the days of Christ
okay with the Sorcerer's and the and the
physicians of the day and so forth
and the 20th century pastor in the 21st
century no different they have all these
false theories when they don't know
something they blame it on diamond they
blame it on genetics okay right
absolutely but they might even blame it
on autoimmune ok body's attacking itself
well it comes down to all of these or
nutritional deficiency diseases and
these are the pre-existing conditions
that are breaking the insurance
companies now and people will have these
diseases for 10 15 20 30 years when we
can get rid of them in weeks we can save
the government so much money we can save
families so much money nobody's
interested in that it's that that kind
of money that you would literally be
taking from that industry by now
creating all of these healthy bodies who
would want to know you well and of
course the cost of doing this through
nutrition per hundred pounds of body
weight because it goes by body weight
per hundred pounds of body weight
it'll cost somewhere between depending
what diseases you have somewhere around
three to four dollars
per day about the half of a cost of a
cup of exotic coffee
yes opposed to thousands of dollars a
pill and the products that you have will
increase your muscian see how do you the
supplements that I'm taking now that you
have given dunk you got me hey your body
has been given by the Lord and that God
is the best physician absolutely
absolutely and God has put into us our
body's ability to maintain repair itself
that requires raw material to do that
these nutrients are no longer found in
our food so our bodies alone cannot do
this anywhere it has the it has the
processes but it needs the raw materials
the body is just a blueprint and so we
need these raw materials for to put to
work to maintain rebuild ourselves and
so what I learned to do through the
animal industry because they don't have
health insurance for animals mm-hmm
right so for instance he doesn't want to
feed a hundred cows and have 25 birth
defects and 75 in normal calves and 25
with birth defects he's gonna go broke
well we gotta quit then we gotta quit
bad listen you you you gotta get more
information his information of his
website and all of his products are
right here on the screen I'm not trying
to sell you anything I just know the
benefit of what this man's knowledge has
done for this man who's sitting right
here before you and so when I get a hold
of something that's going to advance the
body of Christ I'll be the first one
that will run back and tell you the good
news about how you can live and have
this abundant life that God that's good
this is not by coincidence then you are
watching this broadcast you happen to
tune in today to invent your life or
possibly the life of your family members
mom
that you can benefit from this broadcast
next week we're coming back with dr.
Wallach we're going to be sharing again
some of the same awesome information
that you need to just leave your mother
thank you for tuning in that's been the
joy remember life is better when you're
living faith we'll see you dr. Joel
Wallach sprout braking studies over
decades of research have revealed
numerous facts and truth about your
health which are radically different
from what you have been led to believe
by the medical community these findings
have been distributed worldwide through
the material on this phenomenal CD dead
doctors don't lie with more than 200
million copies in circulation recorded
during dr. Wallach lectures this CD
touches on a wide range of subjects
including aging heart disease
cholesterol arthritis cancer diabetes
Alzheimer's and pregnancy in all dr.
Wallach addresses 25 topics and engages
in question-and-answer sessions with the
audience and his book is a comprehensive
expansion of the material on the CD with
over 400 pages of information which can
significantly impact your quality and
length of life you'll learn how to
identify 90 essential nutrients many of
which are not available in food prevent
and reverse 412 diseases with vitamins
minerals and herbs reach your genetic
potential for a long and happy life
eliminate a major portion of costly
medical expenses take responsibility for
your health and much much more dr.
Wallach stead doctors don't lie 400 page
book and multi-million selling CD can
both be yours today for a gift of $40
it's not too early or too late to gain
the knowledge and tools you must have to
rescue and revolutionize your health and
that of your family and loved ones call
or order online today
and so this professor who was trying to
teach newly graduated doctors about
seniors either let's look at this guy
and he said well why Sir do you eat or
what
what do you tribute your youthful looks
doing your youthful blood work as well I
ate 25 of eggs a day
what yeah I've been doing for 17 years
and we dip for the next time you say why
do you eat 25 eggs a day is because it
gives me the sex life of an 18 year old
come home
[Music]
so welcome back we're here some
interesting things I've learned and
we've talked about in our last broadcast
I prayed that you were here and you
heard all of these things this is not a
stranger to the body of Christ nor on
this topic and dr. Wallach is here with
us again and I'm happy to welcome him to
living by faith broadcast doc thank you
for being with me again
Pastor Mike I feel like family I really
appreciate you oh I appreciate you so
much now now just talk yesterday we
talked about eating eggs I've been
removing the yolk from my eggs because
they they giving this information okay
this all started out in 1901 when the
German Navy went to a German chemist by
the name of Wilhelm Norman and Berlin
University said look we need a synthetic
smokeless diesel lubricant for German
submarines by 1904 he'd done it at the
end of the first world war they didn't
need any Morrissey was allowed to sell
it to a British soap manufacturing
company they couldn't sell the soap
because everybody's making their own
soap so they sold it to Procter & Gamble
here in the States
come on and they couldn't sell it
remember this is a diesel lubricant for
German submarines yes sir they couldn't
sell this soap cause in the 20s 30s 40s
everybody's making their own soap and so
they decided to turn into a cooking
shortening called Crisco mmm
remember this is a synthetic diesel
engine lubricant for German submarines
now it's gonna be a cooking churning and
grandma didn't want to use it because
she's using but lard butter creamy
absolutely 40 generations of grandmas
before her well so this guy Fannie Mae
Ancel keys who's the head of Department
of Medicine at University of Minnesota
was on the board of directors of Procter
& Gamble there's also the board of
directors of the American Heart
Association he brokers a deal by which
Procter & Gamble gives the American
Heart Association 1.7 million dollars we
just kind of chump change today from be
institutions back there was a lot of
money yes sir so they took it in
exchange for endorsing Crisco as a
healthier way to eat
butter cream lard neighs mm-hmm they
couldn't sell it
so Ancel Keys goes to an advertising
firm said how do we sell this well I
said you happen to demonize what grandma
was doing so then she'll go to the
heaven peace with church music and
butterflies yes sir is gonna be the
Crisco mm-hmm well they did an analysis
of lard butter cream and eggs they got
two common threads cholesterol and
saturated fat so they started demonizing
that just so they could sell the Crisco
okay and then they threw in the
Mediterranean diet which there was no
research on nothing that just made it up
out of their head and that began to sell
it wasn't romantic so they began to sell
the Crisco well since then we've gotten
about 14 diseases that going to Chris
goes to lard butter cream and eggs
okay we've switched the switch we wanted
with low tea low testosterone needy
erectile dysfunction menopause at age 30
oh wow adrenal exhaustion and
alzheimerís days all those are caused by
a cholesterol deficiency it turns out
that cholesterol is an essential
nutrient and it has nothing to do with
the cause of plugged arteries and plaque
in your arteries it's all it was all a
fraud to sell Crisco and and and so but
people have to be sitting here just like
I when I first heard you some years ago
by what authority do you speak who is
this guy and and you're brilliant all of
the information you have concerning all
of these deficiencies well well Pastor
Mike this thing this story about the
Crisco and yes sir and getting rid of
cholesterol winding up with all these
cholesterol to fish diseases was a to
full-page story in The Wall Street
Journal three years ago now you realize
that Wall Street Journal is a financial
newspaper yes sir when they talk about
health or anything like that it's always
one column wide to Paris long no talking
we're talking two full pages to tell
this story then a couple years later
five
full pages in Time magazine same story
tunnel and nobody paid attention to it
even though on the cover of these things
is telling you about don't listen to
this thing about don't eat the eggs eat
butter don't use margarine eat butter
all the opposite of what the doctors
have been telling us that was all to
sell Crisco
absolutely and so we wound up with all
these diseases now they're happy because
they make billions of dollars each year
for the sale of cialis and viagra and
and premarin which has made out of horse
urine for women to get artificial
estrogen for for menopause at age 30 yes
sir yes sir and then they make billions
no they'd make trillions of dollars on
statin drugs to lower your blood
cholesterol that's what makes the doctor
and the pharmacy companies really happy
because now they get to treat
al-harazi's
which is caused by a deficiency of
cholesterol and your mind is just
clicking away like well that's because
I've done eight thousand human autopsies
I've done forty thousand animals you've
done eight thousand human auto yes sir
and forty thousand animal autopsies from
four hundred and fifty four species of
animals nobody else ever done it before
I'm not smarter than anybody else but
God has put me to possess solutely to to
be confronted with all this information
and as a result I know things that
nobody else knows they've seen it with
their eyes but they didn't couldn't
understand they couldn't interpret it
because they didn't have the information
most of these autopsies that you have
they're published
okay and and you have also witnessed the
deficiency yes sir well this is all done
by biochemistry yes sir you spent
millions of dollars doing the
biochemistry is all the tests and again
this is why my twelve hundred page book
that's my essentially my PhD thesis
mm-hmm twelve hundred page book that
came out of this study is in the
Smithsonian Institute is a national
treasure because you cannot find this
information anywhere else come on so so
these black genetic lines talk about
that okay well this all started when I
actually rebuilt Andy Young sneeze
he's gonna get a double knee replacement
rebuilt his knee so he didn't need the
surgery it was introducing me he's so
excited about it we were talking about
sickle cell anemia and hummingbirds in
Deer and why I could get a quote genetic
disease unquote from the black community
into deer and hummingbirds which is
really just nutritional deficiency not
not genetic as doctors was saying mm-hmm
and so it was able to rebuild Andy young
sneeze with him our nutritional program
so he didn't need surgery and I believe
that's what kind of contributed to my
mom passing away see me that knee
replacement at 80 something like never
done surgery on her right absolutely
rebuilt her and say 90 days and she'd
still be alive today you think God's
principles now
so if creflo dollar and Andy young call
me 90 91 mm-hmm they said look Emory
University's told us that Pastor dollar
his daughter is not gonna make it she's
11 and a half years old she's got a
genetic form of asthma found in black
kids and she's not responding to
maintenance medication or to emergency
medication she's not good to be 12
having so many crises now with asthma
Emory University says she's not going to
be 12 get ready for her loss because
tomorrow you could wake up she'll be
dead mm-hmm it's gonna happen quick say
call me yes I know what's happening here
I can help you I can get rid of that
they were putting their hand over the
phone I could hear him whispering sir
I'm sure pastor dollars say well Emory
University said yes and here's this guy
I don't even know who he is he's saying
he can help her they get back on and so
I said yes I said the reason why if
she's not responding to the maintenance
medication and the emergency medication
if she's not absorbing it she has
something called gluten intolerance
she's her intestines are damaged she
cannot absorb the medication mm-hmm
that's a problem so we need to get her
on your whole family everybody the
family grandma on pastor taffy and mmm
everybody in the household and the cook
and needs to be on a gluten-free diet no
fried foods are processed meats no oil
so glutens no wheat bran oats and then
here's the program for her to rebuild
her lungs and get rid of her asthma and
praise God praise God pastor in two
weeks she was cured never 11 a half year
is going downhill doing she was cured
using God stuff Wow
and so unsolicited a month later I get
this very large check lots of zeros on
it come on pastor dollars come on and I
don't take any money for telephone
consultations giving lectures I don't
take the money for the sale of product I
don't make anything from the sale of the
product I don't want people to think I'm
doing this I love it I love it yes sir I
don't want people think I'm doing this
for the money yes sir I don't make any
money for the sale of products yeah and
so I have to give you this check back
and I'm calling you to tell you this
person because I didn't want you to
think I was rude and rejecting your
check and I just want to thank you for
your kind thoughts he said well kids do
research they say yes sir and what kind
of research we said well after what you
did for my daughter I want you to find
out all the diseases that are said to be
genetic in the black jersey that or not
I'll have a dynamic Carolyn oh you guys
stop right there you got this stop right
there good cuz one once we return we
want to talk about this information that
I've put together and it's gonna bless
your life stay tuned don't go away
hi I'm dr. Joel Wallach and I'm gonna
give you the truth about nutrition what
I would like you to do is give me 90
days to show what the 90 essential
nutrients can do for your health we're
back and I want to get right back into
black jeans lies that's right yeah tell
me do you have a book yeah two CDs to go
along with it and the research was paid
for by pastor Creflo Dollar okay okay I
love dr. dance my main man I think I
fall yeah oh yeah he's been such a
wonder introducing more and more great
things that God does and absolutely hate
him and so any rate he sends me this
money in which I can't take so it wanted
to send it back to me says we'll do the
research with it and and what did he
want reason we can't take it because
you're not in it for the money for the
money you you sincerely want us to know
the man of Christ God's message that's
correct
I love it and so the world yes sir 55
countries have done this in 55 countries
and the United Nation you could be a
very very wealthy beyond well I'm
wealthy and God's yeah I don't have lots
of money but I donated as a pastor
dollar
he sends his money and I say can't take
the money and he says well can you do
research and I said what kind of
research one yeah he says I want you to
find all the diseases that are said to
be genetic in the black community that
are not how to prevent them how to cure
them so I hired a bunch of graduate
students with the money and in six
months time we had all the research I
needed I sent him the manuscript to the
book before in Polish and I wanted his
input this is where we're going with
this is what we found and he was just
shocked because all the disease is said
to be genetic in the black community I
would pressure diabetes obesity heart
disease cancer sickle cell anemia or not
or not no they're not they're just all
simple nutritional deficiencies eases
sickle cell anemia is a nutritional
deficiency in the mother when the bone
marrow cells are farming in early
pregnancy look at real mm-hmm
and so the sort of like cerebral palsy
and heart defects and cleft palate and
Down syndrome
this is a birth defect of the bone
marrow and so it only makes
dysfunctional hemoglobin called
sickle-cell anemia
mm-hmm now it also occurs in animals
because they can get the same birth
defect that's why I booked some
Smithsonian Institute mm-hmm all
vertebrates same deficiency get the same
disease white people also get sickle
cell anemia mm-hmm now supposed to be a
genetic disease elect well certainly and
so they had to change the name and white
guys same disease but they call it
thalassemia and white guys about that
otherwise it would confuse the public of
course yeah right and so when I had to
learn to do was come up with programs to
eliminate sickle cell anemia I would
pressure diabetes obesity heart disease
for instance congestive heart failure as
a pastor you see lots of you with
congestive salutely yes sir
sir we've known for 300 years it's a
deficiency have a single vitamin a
single by yes sir I said the quickest
ones I've gotten rid of congestive heart
failure is a week normally to take me
two months or less get them off all
their medication they're free of
congestive heart failure because it's a
you know for instance when you have iron
deficiency anemia you and I would want
to go to the drugstore and get some iron
of course the doctor wants to do a bone
marrow transplant mm-hmm that's why all
the insurance companies are going broke
cause they're going with all these
expensive treatments to just treat the
symptoms right right yes there's a
nutritional supplementation cures the
disease and some of them people know you
can cure scurvy with vitamin C can cure
berry berry Vaughn b1 plagued with
vitamin b3
hricko's vitamin D you can cure um let's
see here you can cure there's a type of
anemia you get with vitamin b12
deficiency
obviously iron diff there it's vitamin
d3 but night blindness or you can't see
colors at night yes sir it's a simple
vitamin A deficiency where the bunthing
congestive heart failure you said was
live is my ball I don't tell people what
that is because okay I don't want them
to go drop off their medication and get
that vitamin because it might have a
problem what we have is what we call the
healthy brain and heart pack okay which
is a more complete thing because you
have a congestive heart failure
problems yes yes and so we have to deal
with all of that and then we given what
I call the secret sauce which is that
vitamin okay we have that secret sauce
secret so now how can they find out if
we're here well the number you're giving
them yes sir that number the email
address website the telephone number
miss Linda our angel will be their coach
absolutely absolutely and walking
through that step by step and they won't
have to be concerned about their being
in the imbalances we're correct what
they're getting from their doctor and
their medication right when they go to
their doctor for their usual in fact if
they're feeling really really good but I
say go make it actually you know don't
wait until you were supposed to go there
three months around just get an
appointment go ahead see what he says no
I don't know why but you don't have
congestive heart failure tomorrow I get
this all the time with diabetes people
with diabetes for 30 years pastor they
come him so my doctor says I don't have
diabetes anymore not to take any more
medication in 30 days after 30 years
this is God's work it never fails in
there for me I know when I got out of
that hospital after I'm almost checking
out I mean that is where this is very
very very scary is a challenging time
for us all but I got to work on taking
all of those things that you were
telling me about and people are telling
me that I look I don't want to be
boasting about how I look but well you
look like a young man you're skinless
yeah yeah and and that's what I've been
hearing I mean my strength I'm regaining
it's almost deadly and and I just feel a
lot better
the the pressure that I would have
challenges with was known as normalized
and I just thought it was my exercise a
combination of that but this deficiency
that I obviously
now you had lung problems yes sir lungs
I remember em hmm
and of course the lungs make a hormone
to keep the bronchi open okay if your
Airways open mm-hmm if you're not making
that hormone those Airways the muscles
just close it down so instead of being
as big around as a quarter okay your
bronchi to your lungs from your trachea
yeah okay instead of being a dime to a
quarter
they're the size of a dimer of a pencil
oh yeah maybe an eighth of an inch yeah
so say you can't hardly breathe
yes sir - oh you got a life-threatening
situation here we should do yeah well
I've had people who were told they only
have weeks to live they called me in the
middle of night we put them on to 18 of
these nutrients and by the morning time
their bronchi are back open to the size
of a quarter they're perfectly normal
you just have to give him the right
secret sauce right secret sauce yeah and
all of them are gods yeah man's creation
every one of these is a natural
substance okay so did you go back like
to Genesis if you will plant base and
you've researched all the information
that matches certain different
dispositions of the body and have
connected that particular vitamin with
like the lungs and what you just
mentioned the heart and and knock
doctors don't pay attention to this
because they're looking for the drug
that's gonna open up your bronchi
doesn't solve the nutritional deficiency
problem right but the drug will relieve
the symptoms but the disease what's
gonna happen is when you're deficient
that same nutrient you're gonna get a
blood clot in your lung you're gonna get
a bad thrombotic stroke we get a blood
clot in the brain or you get a coronary
thrombosis you get a blood clot in the
coronary artery and die mm-hmm
because the same deficiency causes all
those different diseases mm-hmm well why
aren't doctors talk about that a bit
well let's look for two minutes on some
statistics okay Johns Hopkins very
famous medical school from Baltimore
Maryland okay they came out three months
ago and said the number three cause of
death in human beings in America
is simple mistakes in the workplace of a
doctor mmm third leading cause of death
in America is simple mistakes and
doctors workplace to hospital each year
now this is Johns Hopkins came up with
this just a couple of months ago mm-hmm
published in medical journals every
newspaper in the land had it was on
every TV station mm-hmm
they said each year medical doctors
killed me is a kill where each year
medical doctors killed two hundred
fifty-one thousand Americans from simple
mistakes what would happen if a fast
food place were to kill 251,000 cop Abed
yes yes sir
what would happen if I ran the earth
career were to send over
intercontinental ballistic missiles
absolutely killed 200 to 1000 absolutely
obvious well here's one trade that does
that every year in the workplace and
nothing happens
also we've learned because of these
things our children will be the first
generation of Americans that do not live
as long as their parents you may have
heard that too absolutely
well that is a catastrophic prediction
of biblical proportions that's the same
as telling the Pharaoh the firstborn and
yes yeah if you don't let the Hebrew
slaves go mm-hmm okay and this was gonna
happen if we don't supplement these kids
properly they will all die before we do
how do we get this message out more and
more well you're doing it yes sir
and again it's all in the CDs and DVDs
in the books and we're working hard and
I can't thank you enough for sharing
this with your church family absolutely
and some of them will take it on like
apostles
and sometimes you feel the frustration I
felt it was frustration and then I
thought of Noah and Jesus himself come
on they couldn't get everybody to
everything come on come on come on
we got stop right there doctor we're
coming right back to share with you just
some tips and things that you should
know now stay tuned hi I'm dr. Joel
Wallach and I'm gonna give you the truth
about nutrition what I would like you to
do is give me 90 days to show what the
90 essential nutrients can do for your
health it's been an awesome broadcast I
want dr. Wallach to just give us some
tips but I also want you to get in
contact with them you've heard some
things that's going to literally
revolutionize your life it's going to
change your life it's changed my life my
health is a lot better I'm telling you
I'm doing everything this man has given
me to do you can contact him now his
precious angel he calls her and Linda
she will be on standby just contact her
at this number that's on your screen and
here and you'll have all the information
you'll need from that call I promise you
doc give us a few tips on what we can
start doing now if I got high blood
pressure what what whether I do if I
have diabetes I call how do I guess I'll
give me some tips okay well first of all
all vertebrates again humans turtles
fish flamingos and elephants and
giraffes and rats and dogs and pigs we
require 90 essential nutrients 60
minerals 16 vitamins 12 mystery fatty
acids most multiples in the market have
24 26 28 but not even at three required
none we require 90 of those 90 60 or
minerals now plants won't require three
minerals mm-hmm look good and produce
tomatoes and carrots and okay seeds for
this duration we need 60 okay you're
eating a pretty good-looking tomato
taste good firm perfect tomato you're
only getting three right elements from a
saw your short 57 yes sir yes sir okay
and so we have to consciously some
with these sayings because these
nutrients are no longer found in the
food there's some places in United
States
50 100 and 200 years ago those all 60
minerals were in the tomatoes how about
that now there's only three because our
soul is deficient yes sir well they're
deficient because we went from wood as
the universal fuel to electricity mm-hmm
you're probably old enough to remember
we put wood ashes in the garden
absolutely ashes are not ashes wood
ashes are the minerals that the trees
sucked up out of the ground we threw the
minerals into the garden we ate the
tomatoes and the carrots and the beets
and the cabbage they had sucked up all
those minerals up they didn't need them
but they sucked him up we ate that food
we got the minerals that way we switch
to electricity no more wood ashes in the
house anymore no more wood ashes in the
garden no more minerals the commercial
fertilizers only have the three that
plants need tumbles we went from well 40
50 60 yeah just really right and nobody
knew to make up the difference by
supplementing because nobody knew they
were getting their minerals from the
food okay so now we know this okay cause
we have to consciously supplement and I
like people to get every day every day
right a stick of butter a day okay you
need to eat just take a better day it's
not an apple a day keeps the doctor away
it says take a butter day keeps the
doctor away
okay it helps you get rid of and
reverses Alessandro disease part disease
MS Lou Gehrig's disease hunting disease
all those diseases of the brain are
really the same disease just different
parts of the brain are more severely
affected she has slightly different
symptoms and we were told that a stick
of butter they would kill us well cause
plaque in your arteries income yes yeah
all kinds of our chilled Izzy's no sir
the margarine is the one that actually
does it okay and then of course again I
like people to per hundred pounds of
body weight to eat six to eight eggs a
day mm-hmm and that so you can make
hormones okay testosterone estrogen
progesterone adrenal hormones belonged
to a class of nutrients called steroid
hormones they're 95% by weight
cholesterol mmm and if you get if you're
eating margins at a bar right right
they're eating egg beaters instead of
eggs or egg white omelets instead of
whole egg omelets you think you're doing
good cuz the doctor told you so that's
exactly what you're deficient all those
hormones you're gonna be needing cialis
and viagra and premarin and oh oh Lord
okay I'm gonna mix
they the the kicker was in 1991 there
was an article published in the New
England Journal of Medicine by Harvard
Medical School okay and there was his
old guys 88 years old and he looked like
he's 50 and his blood work showed he was
a healthy 50 year old guy all those 88
years old and so this professor who was
trying to teach newly graduated doctors
about seniors he said let's look at this
guy and he said well why sir do you eat
well what do you tribute your youthful
looks doing your youthful blood work he
says well I had 25 of eggs a days what
she had been doing for 17 years and we
do it for the next one year said why do
you eat 25 eggs a day he's because it
gives me the sex life of an 18 year old
Tom Oh hmm and so this was published is
one of the biggest articles ever written
in the New England Journal of Medicine
eat 25 eggs I'm going to get some eggs
as soon as we in this broadcast and I'm
not here to make light of any of all of
this informations this information at
all this information has really been
they can look it up March 1991 New
England Journal of Medicine you look it
up yourself
you heard it here looking up look it up
and and then please contact his office
that information is on the screen his
darling angel Linda will be there to
take your calls and it's gonna change
your life
I'm glad you tuned in this has been
living by faith remember life is better
when you're living by faith we'll see
you soon
you
dead doctors don't lie with more than
200 million copies in circulation
recorded during dr. Wallach lectures
this CD touches on a wide range of
subjects including aging heart disease
cholesterol arthritis cancer diabetes
Alzheimer's and pregnancy in all dr.
Wallach addresses 25 topics and engages
in question-and-answer sessions with the
audience and his book is a comprehensive
expansion of the material on the CD with
over 400 pages of information which can
significantly impact your quality and
length of life you'll learn how to
identify 90 essential nutrients many of
which are not available in food prevent
and reverse 412 diseases with vitamins
minerals and herbs reach your genetic
potential for a long and happy life
eliminate a major portion of costly
medical expenses take responsibility for
your health and much much more dr.
Wallach stead doctors don't lie 400 page
book and multi-million selling CD can
both be yours today for a gift of $40
it's not too early or too late to gain
the knowledge and tools you must have to
rescue and revolutionize your health and
that of your family and loved ones call
or order online today thank you for
viewing this presentation and remember
to contact the person that sent this to
you for more presentations and books
that go into greater detail go to doc
Wallach Mediacom and be well these
statements have not been evaluated by
the FDA these products are not intended
to diagnose treat cure or prevent any
disease the opinions expressed in this
informational program are the express
opinions of Joel D Wallach BSD VM and D
are not a replacement for proper medical
advice and treatment in all cases we
recommend you contact your physician
directly regarding any medical
conditions